now non-essential retail shops will
begin reopening from the 15th of June
that's a week tomorrow as the easing of
the lockdown continues but how will it
work and what restrictions will be in
place
Chris Wooten is a chief financial
officer of Sports Direct and he joins us
now thank you so much for being with us
and sports directors reopening stores on
June the 15th how are you going to do it
safely people gonna use changing rooms
for example can they bring in cash we be
able to touch the clothes how will it
work and we've implemented a large
amounts of safety measures these include
things like safety stickers on the floor
safety signs screens for the tills
silent isolation stations and a very
detailed pack has gone to a lot of
retail teams this has been signed off by
independent professional experts and
we're we're very comfortable that we can
open in a safe environment you've
described the government's plans for
reopening shops there's a shambles and
why do you think that and they've been
very vague on the guidance I think
privately owned publicly Rito's were
expecting to open on the 1st of June
I've been very public in our views that
the Dominic Cummings for usko led to the
government panicking and pushing that
back and by open car showrooms on the
1st of June which frankly and didn't
make a lot of sense and a lot of
retailers including ourselves have and
stores of significant size which are at
least as big as car showrooms when we've
already been talking about the
difficulties faced by the high street I
mean we've certainly covered on the show
in you for many years now how worried
are you about the future of the high
street and do you think that some
businesses are going to go to the wall
because of this pandemic undoubtedly and
the high streets been in turmoil for
some time it needs all the help you can
get I will credit government on the
business rates relief that we got but
and that's something that needs to be
looked at more permanently to help save
this so the high street because business
rates are a Kishin
you say about saving the high street I
mean what could happen you know if the
support isn't there I'm many more
retailers will go to the wall there will
be a lot less returns now initially a
core Sports Direct try to keep stores
open throughout the pandemic claiming to
be an essential business because she
were you know providing fitness
equipment so on and do you know admit
that that was a mistake just like it's
correct you on that we were just asking
for guidance from the government as to
whether we should stay open and I've
decided to go on Piers Morgan in
mourning and trying to use as a
political football it does seem to be
one rule for us and another for others
and we are we do sell bikes for instance
which is in the central category and
we're I believe we're in the top five by
slurs in the UK we have not opened there
were no number of other retailers which
also sell bikes and have opened their
goddesses clearly very big we decided to
not open because the government did not
refuse to give us the clear guidance
some other retailers have taken one view
and opens so do you think that the
problem is that the guidance that there
hasn't been vague enough it has been
clear it has that now improved
absolutely how's the guidance improve
now and well onions the fathers have
said that non-essential retail climbing
on the fifth thing to do some of their
not earlier than that of course okay now
of course some of the concerns that many
people will have is about the safety of
staff going back to work in these
non-essential businesses so we'll start
that Sports Direct be forced to go back
to work from June the 15th or will it be
done on a voluntary basis and also if
staff members have to self isolate for
example because they're unwell or
because others in their household run
well will they be given full pay and we
understand this is a unprecedented time
and as I mentioned earlier we have got a
full pack of health and safety
procedures which has gone to our retail
teams in the preparation
very successful open stores we have just
asked for volunteers to go in and start
preparations and which has been very
successful and obviously stores will
open up the government guidance and and
our employees will be looking to will be
looking to put the Proby amount of staff
in stores to run them officially I mean
the reason that I'm asking the question
is because you know when I announced on
social media that you're coming on lots
of people clearly feel that you were
almost the unacceptable face of
capitalism there's been stories you know
previously about you know having star
forms there are contracts and so on and
how important is it for you to try and
make sure that your staff members only
have to come back to work if they feel
they can do so safely and well of course
you may say with the only acceptable
face butts and what has not been one the
commented on is the fact we paid us off
in full by April and May and that
includes zero hours contracts there's
not many retailers that or many
businesses this is okay I thank you so
much for coming on the program and
talking a little bit more about how
those stores are hoping to reopen later
in the month thank you